with 149 million customers worldwide
it's no secret that Netflix is the world
champion of streaming video the new
competitors are entering the ring among
them Comcast AT&T and Disney now those
traditional media giants are gearing up
to launch subscription streaming
services of their own entering a crowded
field alongside Amazon Hulu Apple and
others and they're ready to duke it out
for who will distribute your favorite
movies and TV shows I say bring it on
Netflix is no ordinary foe it spends 12
billion dollars a year on content and
it's a magnet for top Hollywood
producers and actors but most
importantly it has a head start of more
than a decade but the three new entrants
have a secret weapon TV brands and movie
franchises people know and love they've
licensed a lot of their classic
programming to Netflix over the years
but now they'll want to bring their hits
back to their own services and that
could pose a challenge to Netflix
[Music]
first up Comcast Comcast corpse NBC
Universal has plans to launch an
ad-supported streaming service by 2020
you need to play to win but you also
have to win to play the company hasn't
said much about what will be on the
service but viewers can expect lots of
content from their film and TV
franchises executives are already
contemplating bringing back the office
Netflix's most-watched show since the
contract expires in 2021 Parks and
Recreation is another show Comcast might
want to fight for an ad-supported
service will be available to around 54
million customers that already subscribe
to comcast cable in Sky and other cable
providers that offer NBC channels and
those without traditional pay TV
packages will be able to subscribe for a
monthly fee but to be competitive
Comcast may also need to pump some cash
into original programming but will that
be enough to challenge Netflix the next
challenger att's warner media AT&T x'
recent acquisition at Time Warner now
Warner Media means the company's bulked
up into a major producer of film and
television content home to the Warner
Brothers Studio and HBO the movies like
The Dark Knight and shows like Game of
Thrones in their corner they could prove
to be a major contender in the streaming
Ring Warner media whose service is
expected to launch late this year is
planning for a three tiered approach to
streaming there will be an entry-level
plan focused on movies a second tier
with original programming and
blockbuster films and a bundle of
content from the first two plus popular
content from the warner brothers library
warner media chose to keep licensing
reruns of friends netflix through 2019
warner has the right to take the show
back once it launches the new service
nothing's set in stone in the make up of
the streaming tears so warner media
could always choose to pivot before
launch
[Applause]
the last Challenger Disney before long
Disney will be operating three separate
video streaming services Hulu ESPN Plus
and a new streaming service called
Disney Plus set to launch in November
2019 the company said it plans to price
the new Disney Plus service at $6.99 a
month almost half the costs of a Netflix
subscription in rockland extra both
sides
Disney Plus will be anchored by
programming from Disney's biggest
franchises including Star Wars Marvel
Studios and original programming and
Disney brought in other big titles like
The Simpsons
from its 71 billion dollar acquisition
of 21st Century Fox's entertainment
assets to make a first impression
now Disney is aggressively removing its
top programming from Netflix but that
move means losing 150 million dollars a
year in operating income which Disney
hopes to recoup in subscription fees
from Disney Plus the challengers will be
working hard to get Netflix on the ropes
but a big challenge will be making up
for the hundreds of millions of dollars
loss from licensing programs to Netflix
that means signing up lots of customers
and keeping Wall Street happy easier
said than done